one of the jobs I read you had before
you made your big success on Mad Men I'm
so curious about this you got a job as a
what they call a set dresser on softcore
porn film yeah like a skinemax movie
right right but that is a job at least
you're on a set you're in something of
show business right I understand that
it was for sure Show Business adjacent
right right even watching that had to
add to your sort of thoughts about how
to be on set I got that job because a
couple of of our friends from college
were all sitting around at like a
potluck dinner we were all lamenting the
fact that none of us had jobs and were
sitting around like what should we do
you know does anybody have a line on a
waiter job a bar to anything the
catering
and our friend goes you know I've been
doing this set dressing thing for these
like you know kind of soft core skinamax
things and we're like really he's like
yeah it pays 100 bucks a day we're like
100 bucks a day that's that's all you
need to live in large like where are you
buying dinner and she's like yeah I
really can't do it anymore it's just
it's just debilitating from a you know
Soul standpoint man and everything else
and I was like I'll do it
I had no concept of what a set dresser I
didn't know what it was yeah basically
it's like you're make you make sure the
set looks looks right so you put all the
stuff in you know you clean the ashtray
or whatever you know matches what it did
at the beginning you take a poll in
those days a Polaroid of it and then you
look at the polar okay the things here
and the couch was here because when they
move the camera you have to move all
that [ __ ] out of the way and and and you
have to move it move it back
it just happened it just so happened on
this thing that there was like naked
bodies in the way and you're kind of
like sorry man hey coming in here that's
actually uh the glass table and you know
but it's actually an important job I
mean I remember on Game of Thrones they
left a coffee cup on the scene and
that's exactly you know the creative hat
yeah you leave a water bottle in the
wrong place and it's all of a sudden
you're not in Westeros anymore you being
the handsome man you are I'm surprised
they didn't say to you hey what about
you let you get in there and and uh you
know you know do a couple of scenes you
know yeah yeah yeah no I I was it was
never offered they did not offer the uh
the set dresser
they weren't thinking it's really crazy
I don't know if uh I I don't remember
the titles of these movies or if they
even had titles honestly
um but I I don't I've never seen one I I
don't maybe they didn't even exist I
don't it's all fever dream I have no
idea but no it's I've never seen them I
don't know if they've seen seen the
light of day I don't think I ever got at
least on IMDb I'm not credited as a set
dresser so